the clearest picture yet of the january
6 attack laid out by the house committee
investigators on prime time television
it's a bipartisan committee and it
shared never before seen video of the
assault and testimony from those close
to former president trump
congresswoman liz chaney called out
members of her own republican party for
denying the evidence
tonight i say this to my republican
colleagues who are defending the
indefensible
there will come a day when donald trump
is gone
but your dishonor will remain
the committee also used video to
highlight the role of far right
extremist groups including the moment
they assaulted capitol police officer
carolyn edwards knocking her unconscious
congressman adam kinzinger is the other
republican on the committee other than
representative chaney and he joins us
now congressman good morning to you uh i
think the the opening question just
seems to be what was the committee
trying to get done last night and from
where you sit did they accomplish it
well i certainly think we accomplished
it and our goal was it was both to you
know it has been a little over it's been
over a year since the attack it's it's
easy to move on we need to get to the
bottom of it so as to remind people of
the truth of what happened there's so
much lies and misinformation out there
but then it's to lay out the top lines
of our case uh of our case of why we
believe donald trump is responsible he
lit the flame he summoned the mob as liz
said uh and why we still continue to
think this is a threat this there is a
threat to democracy that's the most
important thing even more than
accountability out of this is for the
american people to understand that this
could still be a problem democracy is
not safe unless we agree to follow a
certain set of standards i think we did
that yesterday and we're going to drill
into that a lot more over the next
couple weeks well congressman let me
pick up on that because you're
absolutely right democracy is not safe
there's amazing polling from the
university of chicago showing that
something like 21 million americans
don't believe president biden is a
legitimately elected president and this
is the key thing support the idea of
violence in removing him do you think
what you did last night spoke to that
dangerous population in this country
you know i don't know and we'll see when
uh this settles in i think when we're
through the hearings what part of this
part has soaked into
that part of the population that has
been protected from the truth that has
been abused and taken advantage of you
know fundraised off of based on a lie uh
they've been turned into a fearful
population by people that they trust
that lie to him so we'll see if that
changes that what's most important to me
at this moment is to make sure that the
vast majority of americans understand
that the country's a threat and
eventually look history is going to
point back liz said it well with her
your dishonor is forever basically line
is uh history is going to judge this
time
and it's going to people are picking
sides right now on what side of history
they want to be judged on
congressman it's vlad let me jump off on
your comment there and tony's question
there are many people in your party who
are critical of this process there are
many people in the republican party who
continue to this day
to suggest that there was fraud in the
2020 election and yet what we saw from
congresswoman cheney is a
the fact that there have been
members of former president trump's
party
officials cabinet members who have all
testified that they know that this was a
lie including the president of the
united states the then president of the
united states himself he knew that those
allegations were were that he was lying
what are your conclusions to draw on
that
so this is something again we're gonna
flush out over the next few weeks we
know but we want to present it in the
right way but i think it is so obvious
look if the president truly believed the
election was stolen he is not mentally
capable of being president because every
piece of evidence
shown to him done by anybody that's
serious besides wackos on the internet
said that the election was legitimate
and that he was elected president what
we're going to see is how quickly a
conspiracy on the internet ends up in
his ears and attempted to be implemented
i think he didn't believe it like i
think i think donald trump is is very
mentally incapable of being president
but i think he knew that these were lies
but he was desperate for anything
anything he could grasp to stay in power
because he can't lose although he is a
loser he doesn't want to lose and he'd
rather throw out democracy
than he would and actually honor it like
that and look there are a lot of
american people that believe in donald
trump believe uh he's telling them the
truth they're being abused and they're
being lied to i want those people to
wake up and see the truth congressman
michelle here i i have to ask to that to
that point exactly
what is going to be done about it
obviously congress cannot
charge donald trump as you say the man
who attempted a a coup
but
doj can and so do you see that happening
i really hope so if they can look at
this and say that meets our threshold of
evidence look we we have to be very
careful and very clear we're not a
criminal committee we're investigating
the facts but if doj looks at what we're
doing and said that reaches a threshold
to charge i think they should and i
think that's what i hope they at least
look at um but the bottom line of this
is regardless of how many people's minds
turn today or tomorrow this is something
where you know i have a five-month-old
boy now his name's christian i want
christian when he's in high school to
learn the truth about january 6. and as
of today that's still up in the air
because there's a lot of conspiracy
theories out there that say it was the
fbi or say it was antifa or god forbid i
mean i was watching last night that
video again as the hearing was going on
and i remember a member of congress
saying this was nothing more than a
tourist visit
i just shook my head when i thought of
that it was amazing
you said it best congressman kingser
thank you very much thank you very much